par l'état monsieur vincent ledoux
revient pour deux merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre notre département est
en danger pénalisé par le poids des
dépenses sociales pour le compte de
l'état et par la baisse de la dgf le
département du nord malgré les
orientations courageuses qu'il prend se
trouve face à une situation inédite et
insoluble elle ne lui laissent pas
d'autre choix que d'envisager
l'augmentation de sa fiscalité scénario
du pire qui s'il devait être mise en
oeuvre
viendraient alourdir l'impôt des ménages
des entreprises une perte d'attractivité
supplémentaire pour un territoire qui a
déjà trop souffert au plan économique
déjà les maires de ma circonscription
étudient dans la douleur et quand cela
est possible des compensations pour
neutraliser cette nouvelle pénalité à
l'instar de gérald darmanin maire de
tourcoing dont je veux saluer la grande
qualité du travail accompli dans cette
assemblée
double peine aussi pour ma commune de
roncq qui voit ses efforts vertueux
battue en brèche
comme pour mes voisins d'allumer un
neuville en ferrain linselles et
bousbecque oui notre département est en
danger une raison claire et je rigole
face au danger
ensuite je cherche un trou pour me
cacher sachez monsieur le premier
ministre que dans le nord on a le sens
de l'humour mais là on ne rigole
vraiment plus et on ne se cachera pas
non plus votre gouvernement s'est engagé
à annoncer avant fin mars une réforme
concernant le rsa plus respectueuse de
l'avenir des départements
saurez-vous au rendez-vous de la
dernière chance qu'envisagez-vous pour
mettre fin à cette situation
inacceptable et permettre au département
du nord d'aborder son avenir de manière
sereine et pérenne je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
baylet minizoo aménagement du territoire
de la ruralité des collectivités
territoriales monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député le doubs vous ne
rigolez pas moi non plus
car je veux quand même rappeler que si
les départements ont vu leur barque
chargé et vous c'est bien sûr la
précédente majorité
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a anéanti la
fiscalité locale lorsqu'il a supprimé
sans concertation la taxe
professionnelle lorsque vous avez
transférer les routes vers les
départements avec pratiquement aucune
compensation lorsque vous transférez les
tos et beaucoup d'autres choses dont
monsieur le député oui les départements
connaissent des difficultés et ces
difficultés le gouvernement s'applique à
les résoudre
nous avons saisi la main tendue du
président de l'adf dominique bussereau
qui a souhaité que nous puissions
travailler syrie ne resaler très haute
il voulait nsa et cette recentralisation
nous sommes en train de le négocier avec
l'association des départements de france
une première réunion a déjà eu lieu une
autre
bavans lieu dans les jours qui viennent
pour tenter de trouver une solution et
permettre justement aux départements de
surmonter cette tâche immense qu'elle à
l'heure quant à la solidarité qui je le
rappelle encore ça peut être offert
vociférer mais qui a décentralisé la
solidarité qui par nature est une
position régaliennes
c'est le gouvernement de monsieur jean
pierre raffarin qui a collé cette lourde
tâche au département qui d'ailleurs
c'est la petite avec beaucoup
d'application et remarques allemand
alors monsieur le député oui le
gouvernement a largué là et nous
trouverons je suis convaincu qu'une
solution avec les départements
merci à l'est s'il vous plaît on va
retrouver
on va retrouver un peu de sérénité et je
donne la parole à me